yeah you're in control of your happiness
however can I finish my child without a
shot over that comfortable everything
you're saying you would rather spend 30
of the week on you than on the on the
family so you're not raising your child
your child's being programmed to the
social norm and who knows that the child
might be fed up of you I think her child
there were times when I certainly spent
more time with coaches or teachers than
my parents because again I'm spending
eight hours a day in school what what
era has Society flourished putting me
before the family it's not about putting
me know
your child 100 I'm not saying my child
comes before everything but you can't
help it doesn't come before everything
if you want a business before you travel
but I didn't say I'm out of control your
happiness yeah you're in control of your
happiness however can I finish my child
without a shot over that counter for
everything every single thing that I do
I've even stopped working to make sure
that my child was okay I've reduced my
hours to make sure that my child is okay
however doing that I realized if you're
not right mentally you can't think you
need to know because I'm going to be
real here because I'm in denial
Outlet basically that's her Outlet to
make sure she's stably and mentally
correct for her child but it's all for
financial gain
that's just her way basically her meant
her way of her Outlet of her releasing
herself from her child she she'd prefer
to go and do business whereas some
people might do a marathon or and you're
still focusing yourself away but her
point is that it's not if it's not about
profit it's not a business and you know
maybe it is a hobby and maybe eventually
actually my main goal eventually is
turned into a charity it's basically
what my it's my daughter's name I
respect
it's very passionate and I don't live
off it if that was not my age but the
point is you're you're saying you would
rather spend 30 of the week on you than
on the on the family and it's just it's
a modern answer and so when you when
you're when you're saying it's a it's
not a modern answer that's just not true
it is a modern answer you're saying that
like she's not with her in the morning
she's not with her at night she's not
we've had to drop that's maintaining a
child raising a child of Maintenance
okay and then what what the thing is you
can't say that because I raised my child
loads of people will disagree here
you're not really raising your child
because for eight hours a day and then
you get these Independent Women get up
in the morning they do breakfast club
and after Club that's like 10 hours a
day breakfast I'm just saying people do
this like they'll send the kids for 10
hours a day yeah so do you think you're
gonna speak that right for 10 hours a
day yeah your kids at school come on
after Aftercare six o'clock yeah have a
wash watch TV go to bed you're not even
seeing your child no but I see my child
because she has activities every single
day she goes to school so you're not
raising your child your child's being
programmed to the social Norm I don't
agree with that you have to raise your
child because you're not raising your
child I am raising my child
she's right and I mean I feel like that
meditation
my child's not so socially awkward my
child is so confident she teaches a
class of 30 children and 30 people where
does she teach her my classes I run
classes and she's teaches people she's
not she's more confident than the other
when you send your child to school that
you're not raising them you're giving
another so what how did you give it wait
you're giving another adult time just
more time to spend with your child than
you will yeah that's it I mean and I'll
say I went to school but there were
there were times when I certainly spent
more time with coaches or teachers than
my parents because again I'm spending
eight hours a day in school so when you
have one homeroom teacher yeah and they
teach most of your classes in third
grade you're spending eight hours a day
communicating with that homeroom teacher
a parent just can't keep up and we now
have outcomes where kids are getting
brainwashed in schools and now they
don't even know but parenting isn't just
smothering your child 24 7. you know
they are meant to be practicing
Independence they're meant to be meeting
people they're meant to be interacting
they're meant to be in social situations
just because you homeschool your child
doesn't mean to miss out on any of those
aspects you as a mother have a duty to
making sure those are in place it's not
in just in school that they get yeah but
I'm just going off the point the pearl
made like you know that um just because
you know I'm not spending 24 7 with them
every second and I'm sending them to
school exactly that's you know sometimes
it's best for the child is yeah do you
know what I mean sometimes who knows
like the child might be fed up of you um
I'm not saying homeschooling is based
upon you living with your child 24. yeah
but you are saying that if someone sends
their child to school you said they are
working twice a day they're not raising
their children
she is raising her child no no no but
why are you the judge what this is my
opinion that's my opinion like she's got
hers you've got yours I'm just saying
for eight hours a day your child is
under the care of somebody else and for
most people they're going to breakfast
club and Aftercare so that's 10 hours a
day because it's only 24.
you get four hours in a weekday with
your child that is yeah
I understand but your child also also
needs to learn other fundamental skills
they don't need to do it doesn't take 10
hours a day it doesn't take 10 hours a
day ask your question so
I don't know guys wait wait
um you can go all right
um so um you see you're homeschooling
your child would you say now you're
fully raising your child because you're
homeschooling your child is that what
you see like is that your point because
I've been in my childhood and I'm not
raising her that's what you said so what
is it from home schooling perspective
how would you view it I believe I've got
more of an input okay of what I can put
into my child and more of a say whereas
for 10 hours eight hours a day at school
I don't have a sec I'm actually another
question is that why you is that one of
the main reasons you chose to homeschool
your child I chose to homeschool because
I went to school and then I was always
like two three years ahead so in year
one I was in year three in year three I
was in year five and like I'd finished
my work in 20 minutes so why do I need
eight hours a day if I can complete my
work in 20 minutes I'm not saying my
child's me because she isn't but I'm
intelligent enough to educate my own
child I have a question so who has more
influence over your kid someone's
spending eight to ten hours a day with
your kid or someone spending four
the teacher be honest and why do you why
do you think we have these kids that are
coming home literally thinking they're
women like little boys yeah literally
coming home thinking they're women and
women young women literally coming home
and thinking they're men yeah and then
when they get older they're even saying
I want to go back to this yeah Angelina
Jones uh child we went to private school
like Catholic school and and even us
they showed my sister CNN kids why are
they showing a liberal news network to
my my fifth grade child and that's their
point you can avoid a lot of those
problems by homeschooling I mean the
plural the home school is on the right
it's like there's a reason for them but
you're gonna be in there anyway yes
you're going to be in the world
regardless yeah but you need to make
them aware of certain things that you
believe in your family culture or
tradition or whatever otherwise they're
going to be led astray well yeah but
then that is down to you as a parent to
make sure that you raise your child
when they're at school that doesn't
happen you only got four hours with them
how can
yeah I feel like the four hours that's
only okay there's term time you've
turned out to be a modern woman so that
if you're happy with that which is um
so are modern women they think they're
still traditional but if you're not all
of it you're not any of it you are all
you win she's right but why she's right
you can't be in between you can't have
the best of both worlds that's why what
how can because that doesn't function
right it doesn't work okay because then
you're in the house now with your man
trying to make out like you're equal
with arguments and debates I don't think
we said that earlier
if I can't have a say at certain things
you're not going to be happy but this is
the problem you either are where you
went so go and Chase your career or be
it be a stay at home mom
and my husband can be supportive of that
and I can still be a good mum and I can
still be a good person this is what they
mean like modern women live in Duluth
that's delusion Society
and he's happy with it so when does your
child spend time like away from you all
the time look where I'm out now she's
like all the time okay so when when you
said oh she's working like her choosing
to work on her business yeah and those
are the times she's not with her child
yeah two days a week when she still sees
her in the morning she still sees her
night she still she's how is that like
what's the problem with that I don't
like it I said I take accountability for
the fact that I'm I'm on my own child is
away from you all the time so I don't
mean a 24 7 but when did you get time to
raise your child if you're always when
I'm not working I'm accountable I don't
want to be here I want to be at home
with my child but because I don't have a
partner at home I'm here because I'm
doing whatever I'm doing with my work or
whatever and I'm here but if I had a
choice which is what I said I would love
the idea of spending seven days a week
every day wait with my daughter because
I don't get ever get bored of my child
and she never drives me insane
and you wouldn't happen you wouldn't
have any hobbies
wait wait wait wait wait wait okay stop
but that's what I'm saying she she has a
real mod or a real traditional mindset
because she's she's actually talking
about putting the kid before the family
and not her you didn't hear her talking
about her do you think that I'm in the
kid before though spending 24 so I would
hate that I would hate no but there's no
idea to say that I should be with my
daughter 24 7. no you're being ignorant
to what I'm saying because I'm saying my
daughter goes to classes my daughter
goes to classes my daughter interacts
with other people your choice would be
to be okay let me let me just let me
just what's better what's better a
stranger spends 10 hours a day with your
kid or the mother spends 10 hours a day
with your kids I don't statistics
adult you're spending 10 hours a day
with people your age people that you can
relate to yeah I'm just gonna repeat the
question is what is better a mother
spending 10 hours a day with her child
or a stranger spending 10 hours a day
I think her it is a stranger
I think school I think school is good I
don't think it's not black and white I
don't think school's good at all I think
the system's failed like a long time ago
the whole point is that you're allowing
a stranger to have more influence over
your kid than you do and we see it you
see it constantly where these kids come
out super left when they come from
conservative homes
it depends on how much input you
actually put into your child but what
are you going to get with four hours a
day I think it all comes down to how you
race your children yeah I really do and
they have their own mind and you know
they're going to get exposed to the real
world eventually and it is down to them
to make their own decisions
that's how my parents raised me and I
think I turned all right you turned out
modern and that if you're happy with
that I respect that and I think if you
want that in your life what do you mean
by modern you keep you keep saying
modern as in like as Paul said you you
classed as the modern woman but I
understand you're still saying you've
got Traditional Values and whatnot but I
I just that's why I'm happy to be a
stay-at-home mum
like how can you be a stay at home if
you want a career you can't have
everything like you don't make no sense
I'm happy to win the lottery
you can't have both well I mean I my
career is like always going to be there
that's the thing even when I'm a mum I
might take a small break off TV and
stuff but I will be back that's a long
career that's her whole point though is
that you're a modern woman because it
but it doesn't mean you're you're a bad
woman because you're in moderate and she
doesn't like the modern mindset okay
fair enough
I'm I have a question about what you
said about children being able to make
up their own minds
um
I I kind of disagree with that and the
question that I want to ask is if
children can make up their own minds
like Pearl said there's kids that are
coming from conservative families and
coming out of schools leftists if a kid
can have their own mind what do you
think about a 13 year old boy your son
for example coming home and saying mum I
want to be a girl
I'm absolutely fine with it so you would
let your 13 year old son go for a sexual
transition because if they have their
own minds they can make their own
consent and they don't need yours if
this is how they are feeling I don't
know the the depths of this but like if
he is feeling like that or she is
feeling like that then it's something
that we're obviously gonna sit down and
talk about and look into if they have
their own minds they don't emphasize
it's just like you're a modern woman
because you still you're abiding by
modern principles that are out today
well I am modern then if that's the case
if my son came home from school one day
and said to me look mum I'll be honest
with you I I think I'm gay I would take
it on
what if you're what if your son came
home and said I think I'm black
well I mean obviously I would I mean
obviously I'd have to sit him down and
be like so you don't think if he thought
he was the opposite gender you might
need to sit him down and tell him that
he's well that's what I said I mean I
would listen to him sit him down and
have a conversation with him but this
all comes down to the way that you raise
your children but you you said they have
their own mind so why doesn't he make up
his own decision why would you have to
sit him down
what do you mean sorry because you said
you said they have their own mind yes
and they can they're making their own
decision but I can still have an input
and I can still talk with him so if he
wanted to change his gender you'd let
him
no of course not I would have a
conversation with him I would find out
like what is this about talk to me like
what if what if the teachers already had
10 conversations with him about this
before you
and they're telling him that it's okay
yeah how much influence are you really
gonna have
and I've seen this I have a younger
sister it depends how young my child is
that's yeah
they give consent forms for those stuff
like yeah they're gonna have lessons
about that they give consent forms you
can actually say you don't want your son
in the room that's just delusional
because if if my daughter goes to class
and all her friends are doing a certain
lesson when they go in the playground
kids are just they're going to tell each
other do that regardless of the lesson
no but like for example my parents you
know they were religious and I remember
when I was younger they got sent a
letter about oh can we show kids sex ed
videos or whatever my parents actually
said no we refused why are you going to
avoid it in a school system it's all
about how you how you actually raise
your children and you don't agree with
you don't but you also don't know what
the teacher's intentions are I mean I I
have a friend that was like sexually
assaulted by a teacher and that's the
risk you're putting at your kid I sent
my daughter to school and like she
didn't two years and it didn't work and
then when the kovid thing coming well
the thing came in and you couldn't like
drop your kid when you dropped them at
the gate and whatnot I just wasn't with
that I don't like the idea of somebody
being more empowered than me with my
child because that then means they have
more power over me and I'm supposed to
be the mother
it doesn't make sense yeah but then
where where does it sort of stop where
do you sort of draw the line because I
mean I don't know a pilot's intentions
for example I don't know his background
I'm very very special
can I ask one question here well a lot
of these kids are going to sway like we
leave them to social media so there's
not really one kid that doesn't have a
phone yeah a tablet or whatever I limit
my childhood you need to protect the
children you should protect the children
you can't just be dropping your children
off the classes and people children get
abused and also protect your child from
the school environment is that right I
don't I'm not with anything that the
school system I I absolutely would I
mean I
and do we even need the school system in
society now no we don't I feel right
there is college like professors that
have openly said things that
discriminated against men when I was in
college
openly and like there's no pushback but
not everyone has the ability to
homeschool their children because you're
saying you're intelligent you can do
that but not everyone you don't really
need to be that intelligent it's like I
could probably educate my daughter to a
certain level but there's so much about
really my brother's 15 years old he
showed me his like GCSE maths test and I
was like what the hell and I have a
degree yeah there's ways to do it though
you'd have to get a true and they
couldn't come to the house or whatever
way you've got more control and say and
import and raising your child but
traditional women would rather work hard
at their chill at their children than
for themselves it makes sense yeah
so what if your child like one day said
oh I don't want to be homeschooled would
you like taking I let my dog I never let
my daughter stay out of the house I just
don't like her staying out I let her
stay at her cousins because I had a
family emergency she stayed there three
days and she wanted to go to school so
this is the effect of other children I
believe and I said yeah okay you really
want to go to school within a couple of
days because you know what I'm I don't
want to go to school she sees school as
a prison because it looks like a prison
so that's my daughter's Natural Instinct
of looking out of school okay cool well
that's interesting to be honest most
kids don't like school they don't my
little brother hates school because all
they're doing is being prepared to go to
work for eight hours a day what you were
saying about like the amount of energy
um obviously Like a Stranger teacher or
whatever you want to call it is putting
into the child when I was in school
there was always like one or two moments
maybe like once every Academic Year
someone would call the teacher mum and I
think that's an accident I think that's
because there's someone there's someone
in front of them you know for however
many hours a day like it might be a
silly point but I don't know
your caregiver if you have a question
you ask them you ask them can I go to
the toilet you talk to them in a way
that you would a parent and then like
you get these kits off put their hand up
mum and then everyone lost but it's like
I don't think that's an accident I think
that's you know they I feel like the
schooling system I agree they will they
want you to see these teachers at the
same time I still feel like some people
go into school from if they're from a
certain different background is actually
Escape for them so I feel like although
we can look at school in a negative way
there could be people coming from
abusive backgrounds when they go to
school they meet that teacher who's
actually uh that's just how similarities
programmed it for people like that's
just how it goes yeah but I mean yeah
but why do we go to the extreme yeah
we're not wait we're not we're not
talking about the exception we're
talking about the rule most people
aren't being abused at home the majority
of people do you think that's majority
of the majority of people aren't being
abused by their parents no but I'm just
saying there's so many people that are
coming from a household where it's not
they don't they're not in they actually
want to go to school they want to go
into that environment meet people be
around people there's some people that
school for me I I hate to school
absolutely hate it didn't work for me
but someone else might love it and I
feel like they should be able to have
the option then they're destined for an
average normal working day that's what
they want right because the people some
people's got to make the world go around
so maybe they're the people for the job
but if you're happy with that for your
child then to send my child to school to
prepare for work in life that's what
school is then at the same time I feel
like that's where your family life and
your parents come in because I went to
school and I was prepared for a working
life but then my family background
okay I think he prepares you for the
real real world as well you can work
with it's just routine you can obviously
you're around different cultures back I
believe yeah
but we haven't you could travel with
your family if you're homeschooled yeah
let's be honest if you ain't got the
money the most you're going to travel to
always like probably the park around the
corner no no no in all the little
swimming bars like I'm telling you like
from the hood because I'm from the hood
from seriously like where she where I
could see sorry I don't know your name
where she's coming from where she's
talking about working or whatever I
don't know her background but I know
she's talking like that because
obviously she wants to leave a
foundation for her you forget the man or
whatever yeah but mine will do that but
I'm saying like what value it's all
based on financing what value does
knowing the real world help to a kid a
five-year-old it helps it you're
supposed to protect your kid from the
world definitely definitely but then you
gotta prepare them for the real world as
well no one knows when your time
expected the best way to prepare your
child it's like morals and principles
not based on money because people have
money and have no morals in principles
so how can that operate it's just a
disaster waiting to happen or happening
I feel like modern society is all based
on money and finances like we're being
pressurized to work so hard to come away
from our children so our children become
the next disaster in society yeah
it's struggle is not struggle is good
for children so like what's wrong I
struggled and like I want my choice it
depends you could go one or the other
way that's why there's crackers and
that's why it is yeah but why why why is
there why is there crackheads though why
are there crackers like why because her
life hits you it depends on how you take
life mentality that's built at home
though no listen you can have a strong
mum but the way you take on life and how
you take on your trials and tribulations
you could either build from it or it
might knock you down
do you know what I mean or you might
look at the wrong person as an
influencer we're talking about children
here no no this is yeah
12 and under why do they need to go
through a bunch of trials and
tribulations no they're not 12 13 the
majority of their childhood 12 13 and
under like why do they need to go to
author Obama and see the real world
where's your environment it's learning
to adapt
like
it's it's different when when
I think if you look at everybody in this
room everyone's encountered some kind of
struggle in the life like it's all
different based on our Arts is all
different because of how your you take
on things how I take I agree with how
she you get what I'm saying so yeah it
all but I just find that every time I
speak and get into this mic like
everyone's perception is all based on
money and finance it's the number one
thing money money money money that's all
you hear like everything's accustomed to
that and I understand you need it to
survive but years ago people survived
then less and built better families and
better children but that's because you
could go into the garden and you know
it's different now it's the same people
start struggling to heat their home
people have always been struggling
though like people have always struggled
being born today you're richer than most
people were in all human history yeah
you are people want more 2023 people
want more because they can see more and
the more greedy to things I just want
everything I'm interviewing a housewife
um she raises she raised 10 kids done
less than ten thousand dollars a year
that's what I'm saying don't eat out
they don't travel they they just it's
not about money she sells their clothes
she she goes in the car I mean and it's
hard oh my God it's hard work I was just
listening I'm gonna do an episode of
wife school where I actually go out and
like look at the children that was that
sure did any of their children go
through bullying or anything like that
oh her children turned out great they're
like very like they have so many
traditional skills that are so helpful
in the in the modern world like sewing
what's the outlook on life like what
experiences
experience I'll show you guys an episode
of watching I'm excited I wasn't gone
yet but yeah that's gonna be interesting
but it really showed me just like the
benefits of a traditional lifestyle and
like I always thought that you needed a
certain amount of money to raise kids
but then I'm hearing this girl saying no
I just I I'll be an honest if I went
back to Jamaica like where my family's
from I wouldn't be focused on no money
like that because I know that there's
Riches of just the land yeah that's the
environment
it's it's different when your hair is
different yeah no she's in she's in
Florida
so it's not but it's sunny in Florida
that alone is a richest
people in the UK we don't we get that
about maybe three weeks or four weeks
what does that have to do with your
spending I think yeah it's like the sun
yeah it proves her point but for example
okay like I get what and they were
trying to say at the back that basically
yeah
um that when you're in Jamaica that you
can grow your crops there's more like
you've got more access to do growing
your own things on your own land whereas
in London if you live in like I don't
know in the city kind of Center you
can't really grow your course able to
budget a bit better whereas I feel like
in London you can budget but it might be
a bit harder right but can't you move
money is the be-all like the everything
when I speak to people women especially
the main thing they talk about is money
money that's the main focus in the
western world to live outside of London
yeah but like I'm from Birmingham like
if I really wanted to I could live on 20
pounds a week if I really wanted to like
it's possible but people don't want it
to be possible because they value money
over anything else maybe have you seen
the energy prices I have seen any
deposites have got a house like I'm not
afraid of the bills there's people on
Universal Credit right now how much are
they getting about 300 to 400 pounds but
there are people on universal credit
with five children and they're happier
and better yes there is no which before
you're seeing you've got social media
everybody
do you think that people are happier in
2023 than they were 100 years ago know
no okay they were poorer 100 years ago
yeah but people were just more content
with life they had better Mr rules and
princess now we're not content with life
there is because there's no morals and
principles because modern women want
everything the expenses of running a
household is different it's not just
that even the kids
has gone up if you look at
um in the U.S they look at they measure
poverty right and they have like a
poverty rate and economists measure it
and they found that people that were
living in poverty had TVs
that's something it's a lifestyle yeah I
mean there's people like for example
where I'm from in Morocco so people
prioritize lifestyle over family that's
that's the bottom line of it it's true I
feel like you don't want children
and have no money so you want to have
money with your children so you're
putting the money before that because
you're willing to do what do you mean
sorry you don't want children and have
no money like that's not an option for
you no yeah so that and I speak for
example because I can't put my kids
through that
what are you putting them I don't want
my kids so you need money to raise your
child basically because you always want
better for your child absolutely but how
is money better for your child I don't
get it so like because so I can answer
your questions about moral's values and
principles are more important than money
absolutely no matter and no matter what
you make and no matter what you make in
2023 you are still richer than most your
kids will be richer than most kids were
wait most kids were in all of human
history so all in all of human history
the kids didn't they didn't turn out
horrible they weren't traumatized I mean
this trauma [__] this is like the last
10 15 20 years people didn't like that
was for me wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait that was for people that came
back from war
it wasn't for your ex-boyfriend cheated
on you five times
yeah that's so true but also I feel like
going back to that point
um you could I I feel like I could be
the best mother I could raise my kids
with you know the best morals and you
know
all of that right and if I do not have
money to give my son he could go out and
steal he could go you could give your
son all the money in the world and he
can still steal he couldn't go outside
rich kids steal to Renton to stab
somebody because I could not afford to
give myself that yeah
you know you're just proving her no
because wait wait you're just proving
her point because she's saying that it's
about morals and values
and you're going back to you're proving
your point because you're saying no it's
about money she's saying no it's about
worlds and values then you say no it's
about money because if we don't have
money he's gonna steal and she says no
it's about morals and values
and I'm saying back to that that I could
bring him up with the best Smalls ever I
could be like listen we are this kind of
conditioner you can swing that every
direction that you've never reached and
he could still steal because it happens
let me finish when he is seeing other
children with iPhones and nice nice
trainers doing these things and he comes
home and I as his mother I cannot afford
to buy him that phone I can't afford to
pay his phone bill he is going to go
down the wrong path
all these guys who are in gangs and are
banged up they come from broken homes
the majority of them come from broken
homes giving your child everything
financially yes
I'm not about spoiling them I personally
believe yes a child has his own has his
or her own mind by a certain age no no
and they're going to be whoever they
want to be based on what you put into
them that's fine yeah but they have
their own mind but I understand they're
gonna steal don't matter what background
to come criminals are from all walks of
life but they are more likely to still
when they don't have it at home now it's
not about money it's about single parent
homes
at single mother homes that's where most
criminals come from yes yes yeah single
parents at homes and and they come from
broken homes it's from women's poor
decisions yes
important decisions some of them have
abusive dads some of them have alcoholic
dads I mean the list goes on so it was
the choice to have a child with an
alcoholic dad but you don't sometimes
always do that you can know typically
yeah
it was your choice not to bet him enough
before you had a kid with him what do
you mean not even an experience
happening
something someone dies in his family or
he loses his life
you can pick you could pick someone that
doesn't drink no okay well I'm gonna go
out and ask for someone here hold on
hold on you see the Kardashians who was
the one that went yeah
everything and everything in life is
your own fault no if I understand your
decision
you can prevent something
whose fault is it no one ever wanted to
pick shoes whose fault is it then the
out your outcomes in life whose fault
are they hours they're all four so if
you pick bad men or you pick a man that
doesn't stick around whose fault is that
I was it's not always what if the person
no you can't say it is
if you have a bad judging character
whose fault is that
I don't think I don't like we spoke
about this before people change so
that's irresponsible for them to say but
are you saying but like you have a legal
change so you can't say that okay like
for example that yeah you still meet
someone and they're not an alcoholic and
they become but it's still your choice
you've got to take accountability for
the more you choose that one thing I
understandable so you could look at
their family and think Hmm his dad's an
alcoholic his grandpa even if the person
changes yeah even if the person changes
you still have to sit down and take
responsibility if that person for
example um if that person does change
you can say okay I made this choice that
was my choice I get that however people
don't like I said people change so if
I've chose this person beginning and
everything but you still got a statement
I checked yeah I will take
responsibility at that time I've chosen
this person they've changed they've now
walked out of my child's life that's my
error because I I didn't see my fault I
didn't see the signs from the beginning
maybe they weren't there but it's my
error I get that you can take
accountability however you can't
sometimes you can't see it from the
start because it's not there but it's
still it's still your respect there's no
responsibility when it happens not you
can't just say so it's still a poor
choice
I'll be real because life life events
changes people so say for example their
mom might have done and that was their
close shooting the person that actually
they could talk to and choose with them
that could just throw them off do you
know what I mean yeah
we're not looking at the people that
have entire midlife crisises that's what
you're saying it's your fault basis in
general yes your choices are your fault
your outcomes it depends on the surface
if you pick a guy that can't get through
the mother of his his mother dying
that's how you meant to know that though
how
90 90 of single mothers like there are
warning signs there are warning signs
you know it they know it there was I I
don't know about that I don't know I
don't know about that I think that's a
bit
that's a bit biased to be fair because
you might have I don't think boys I just
think
past Behavior yeah that's how our brain
works like it's how it's literally all
of work for all of human so time like
your brain goes off of I think women
live in a state of denial and like
that's where there's a problem you can
look at his parents like did he did he
have a stable family to look up to like
there are warning signs I do agree with
that point but even if there's warning
signs or if there isn't like it happen
whatever happens happens it's still your
choice regardless of what the the past
is you can judge the past and still get
it wrong it's still your fault it's your
life sometimes in life you take hours
and yeah it's still your fault you took
the L yeah and I think when you're in
denial you create a bigger Mess by being
in denial of your I mean it's easier to
take accountability so that was my fault
and think what can I learn from this but
you're not gonna keep moving you're
never going to learn if it's not your
fault yeah yeah well then that would
make her the person like pick a better
partner I guess yeah yeah if you take
accountability but if you say oh people
change there was no warning signs then
you're going to make the same mistake
again and again and then you're going to
keep blaming everybody out and that's
where women get bitter and say men are
trash but it's not that's what I said in
the beginning of the podcast maybe
sometimes you need to look in yourself
like to see what you can fix within
yourself by being more accountable I do
agree with that actually yeah yeah true
yeah that's still and this is why I say
red flags are very important take and
leave it literally but maybe sometimes
you're the red flag
[Laughter]